[Music]
oh hell
no move hey PG-13
please what was that Lord is the queen
bee Regina George don't look her in the
eye you could be really hot if we change
like everything
met welcome to health and human
sexuality we will be getting into
abstinence of course Then followed by in
the spring condoms and choking you're
learning things now that I don't know
how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet Baby
E we as women have to be able to support
each other get in loser welcome Katie
you're never going to believe what I
found this morning your burn book mom go
make snacks for sure for sure Regina
yeah
do you like gum sure oh no I don't have
any I was just you're a mess we will
help you
caddy why are you dressed so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
that is shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay all we've done is to make Regina
hotter and revive the wet look dance
break
[Music]
who wrote all this
junk K pushed her Regina really should
be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't even
see it like a face
breast p c incorrect you have to pick a
French name Chanel
no no
[Music]
beyon